[Music]
dear
child I see your
eyes the belonging you seek is not
behind you it is
ahead the Droid I'll pay for
him actually the droids not
sail come
on I can do
this the TR stole a Freer the two were
accompanied by a
girl what
girl chilling we're home this Droid has
to to get to the resistance base as soon
as possible he's carrying a map to Luke
Skywalker Don't Tell Me a rater has got
to
loose I got a bad feeling about
this the girl I've heard so much
about don't
move I'm in charge now
it's about time you showed
up give it everything you
got you're
afraid but you will never be as strong
as Darth
Vader we're not done
[Music]
yet you might need
this
ow
[Music]
hey
goodness Play
Station